I'm probably the only one in this room old enough to remember that when you
wanted to use a computer,
it made a 15 minute walk across town.
And my case from University College London where I was a student,
uh,
to some my Nas Senate House,
where in this entire building was housed.
I think it was an IBM three 60,
something like that.
And you go with a pocket full of punch cards and hand them across a desk and
sign all sorts of forms and got back the next day to see what had happened.
Uh,
now the astonishing increase in processing power that has occurred during my
lifetime encapsulated in the famous Moore's law,
uh,
is due almost entirely to the properties of quantum mechanics.
Quantum systems,
whether it's electrons and photons.
And the architect of quantum mechanics was one Erwin Schrodinger who put
together a what we would now understand as a,
the fundamentals of this subject in the late 1920s add add a stroke.
Quantum mechanics explained the nature of matter all the way from atomic nuclei
right up to the structure of stars.
It's the most successful scientific theory behalf.
So it's not just a in the computing industry that it's had an impact.
It's really right across,
uh,
technology.
Uh,
more than that.
Quantum mechanics provides us with our deepest account of the nature of reality.
It's not just the nature of matter,
but the nature of reality as well.
And it's a subject that continues to intrigue and baffle.
Mainstream scientists.
Schrodinger was a giant of theoretical physics.
This was a very difficult subject and he is rightly given the credit along with
Heisenberg and direct for founding it.
Now,
fast forward to about 10 years.
And,
uh,
the scientific scene took a turn for the worst with the rise of narcism in
Europe and many people fled some to work on the allied war effort trading or who
was Austrian also fled.
But instead of joining the ally,
boring fit,
he settled in Dublin.
Ireland was neutral during World War Two,
and he made a home there with his wife and his mistress living under the same
roof.
Apparently he's still had many affairs.
It doesn't prevent him.
Uh,
and,
uh,
he turned his attention,
I suppose.
Uh,
having sort of got out of the mainstream,
uh,
to whatever it was that interested him and he decided,
that having cracked the problem a matter,
maybe he could crack the problem of life.
And he delivered a series of lectures in 90 43,
which became a very famous book published in 44 by Cambridge University press
called what is life
asking that basic question.
Uh,
and you might say,
well,
what is so special about life?
I think all of us have that impression that living organisms are in a class
apart.
That they're unlike any other complex systems.
They have a rather extraordinary properties.
Uh,
any deed rather baffling properties.
I'm not sure if he was interested to know was whether life living organisms or
could be explained by physics.
Then the question was could it be explained by known physics or did it need any
new physics?
Might there be some sort of laws of life and Schrodinger's open minded about
this?
He said that one must be prepared to find a new type of physical law prevailing.
It it.
So notice it's not just a new physical law,
but a new kind of law.
For many,
many years,
I was skeptical that we would need new physics to explain knife.
Uh,
I just thought our difficulty in understanding and living systems was due to the
fundamental complexity of living organisms.
But over the last few years,
I've become convinced that we do need some new physics.
And so,
uh,
we might think of biology as the next great frontier of physics.
I think there's new physics lurking in biology,
which could have a sweeping implications across the whole of science.
Now,
a contemporary of trading our Max Delbruck,
I think express very nicely the puzzlement that we all feel when thinking about
living organisms.
And they'll be just a quote.
What he said here,
the curiosity remains to grasp more clearly how the same matter,
which in physics and chemistry displays orderly and reproducible and relatively
simple properties arranges itself in the most astounding fashions.
As soon as it is drawn into the orbit of living organisms,
the closer one looks at these performances of matter in living organisms.
The more impressive the show becomes.
The meanest living cell becomes a magic puzzle box full of elaborate and
changing molecules.
And to condense this message a while Delbruck is saying is that when we're
dealing at the level of atoms,
it's just now in physics,
but at the level of cells it seems like magic.
And what is the source of that magic?
Uh,
what I want to tell you today,
uh,
briefly,
is that,
uh,
that wall of secrecy,
mystery that is surrounding the nature of,
uh,
living systems.
I think there's a chink in that and we can begin to see where the answer lies,
uh,
to explain the astonishing properties of living things.
Now,
let me just enumerate some of those properties and their implications.
Uh,
organisms seem to have a sort of inner motive power.
They seem to be self propelled.
Something goes right back to Aristotle.
Uh,
why did I get about that?
they operate as if they have a project or a goal or a purpose.
Obviously human beings do,
but even a humble bacteria and pokes around seemingly knowingly,
uh,
looking for food or something,
they seem to know what they're doing.
Uh,
they,
unlike mes systems,
they create order out of chaos.
Uh,
there's a natural tendency,
I'll talk about it in the moment.
The second law of thermodynamics for systems to degenerate and become more and
more disorderly.
It's easier to break it,
the make it then anyone here with teenage children will know exactly what I mean
when you inspect their bedrooms.
Living systems are self organizing and they evolve in an open ended way.
You cannot really predict in advance if you got an a time machine,
my back 3 billion years and there were just these sort of boring bacteria.
If you try to predict the future of the biosphere,
that would be trees and bees and cacti and so on,
you couldn't do it.
It's an open ended and seemingly boundless possibility space
living organisms.
I suppose they most characteristic feature,
at least the one that intrigues me is that they achieve seemingly impossible
states.
That is they achieve states of matter that could not arise in any other way from
nonliving systems.
And I give some examples later on and this race is a how question.
Like when I,
when I decided I would write a book about what is life about the nature of life.
A lot of my biology friends,
we're a bit baffled by that.
You know,
what's the problem?
We study life,
uh,
and of course biologist study what life does not,
what life is.
And the big issue for a physicist is that all this wonderful life,
which once it gets going keeps,
keeps going,
it all works very well.
It perpetuates itself.
So once the system is up and running it's fine.
But how did it get started in the first place?
And that's a really important question because everybody I think wants to know
are we alone in the universe?
And the answer hinges on adjust,
how likely it is that life starts up from non life.
What is it?
What is the process that uh,
if you like animates matter,
what is the process that makes normal matter living matter?
We don't know.
But if this is something which is incredibly unlikely,
if the chemical pathway leading from a mishmash of chemicals to the first living
thing was very long and convoluted,
it may have happened only once in the entire observable universe,
in which case we are it,
there is no life anywhere else.
Alternatively,
if this is something that is this process as pathways built into the fundamental
nature of the universe,
then we could expect that life will come.
Uh,
wherever there,
there are opportunities wherever they are earth like planets,
university will be teaming with it.
So this is a really important question.
Now we're hampered in this entire discussion about life,
uh,
because we don't have a life meter.
This is what it might look like if you had one.
Um,
what we would ideally like to be able to do,
particularly in searching for life elsewhere,
is to send a life meter off to Mars or tighten or wherever you happen to think
life may look.
Uh,
and it will come back hopefully with the reading showing,
yes there is life there.
But we also feel that the transition from non life to life isn't going to be an
abrupt thing.
It's not just some amazing gigantic chemical reaction that just sort of happened
one day.
There's going to be this pathway.
We don't know whether it's a lot of jumps or just a slow rise.
We don't know what it was cause we have no idea what that pathway was.
Um,
but wouldn't it be nice if we could go to somebody like titan sample,
the atmosphere,
which we know is full of organics and this life meter would say,
well nice try titan.
You've been there four and a half billion years trying to cook up life.
Didn't quite get there,
but you did get 83.7% of the way there.
Come back with a,
that was almost life will be no almost life if we saw it.
We know life when we see it.
But can we tell the difference between something that's living,
something's almost living.
Something that was living in no longer is now,
this seems like a very sort of academic exercise and it's a type of question
we'd love to discuss in the beyond center at Arizona State University.
And we sit around and we argue about this and define this and we think we've got
our own approach,
which I got to talk about in a moment based on the informational properties of
these systems.
Uh,
but there's a very practical sense in which it would be nice to know the answer
of how to build a life meter.
We had a conference couple of years ago,
uh,
and presence in the meeting was Chris Mckay from Nasa Ames.
So it's an astrobiology lab.
And we were trying to convince him that,
uh,
a true definition of life was a software definition,
not a hardware definition.
That definition based on the patterns and Organization of Information,
uh,
it should be substrate independent.
What we'd like is a universal definition of life that would apply whatever the
chemical basis.
Uh,
and we've got some ideas about that and a little bit abstract and so on.
and Chrysalis response was,
well,
this is all very exciting and well and good,
but I have to tell NASA,
hey,
quarters,
by April the 24th,
what we're going to put on this spacecraft and the spacecraft a is going to go
to a moon of Saturn called Enceladus.
Some people say enchilada.
Uh,
and you see that from the surface of Enceladus or these,
this plume of material coming out now and sell it as has our,
an icy crust but illiquid interior and the Cassini spacecraft measured organic
molecules coming out in that gas.
So it was,
Chris says,
it's almost like at salad,
this is put up a sign saying life free samples.
And so what they'd like to do is fly a spacecraft that I go through that a plume
and put a life meter on board and tell us,
you know,
is,
is there life there or not?
But what,
as soon as you start thinking about exactly what the you put on that spacecraft,
you hit the,
what I regard as the fundamental problem with trying to,
uh,
understand what is life.
If you ask a physicist to describe life,
then you're going to have,
or a chemist,
you're going to have a description in terms of falses.
And molecular shapes are definitives and binding energies and entropy and the
energy and all that fun stuff that you learn,
uh,
in,
in physics degrees.
Uh,
if you ask about ologist,
you get a very different narrative.
So biologists will describe life in terms of coded information,
uh,
instructions,
editing,
transcription,
translation signals,
uh,
all of those sorts of things.
And to summarize that in terms of information,
so physicists talk in terms of hardware,
stuff,
biologists talk in terms of software or information.
And very much in the news of the moment is a gene editing.
So sales,
we'll edit their own genes,
but now we can do it artificially,
we can intercede.
And so we have two very different conceptual descriptions of the same
phenomenon.
And you might think,
well,
that's a problem.
Uh,
but,
um,
uh,
one of my scientific mentors,
John Wheeler,
was fond of saying that revolutions in science,
Omar to the clash of ideas than the steady accumulation of facts.
And so when you see something like this twin narratives but completely different
conceptual basis,
that's where progress in sands is likely to come.
Now,
if there are any doubters in the room that think information,
uh,
is not terribly relevant to biology,
let me just run through some obvious examples.
Uh,
the DNA in your body's is packed full of coded information.
It's not just information,
it's encoded.
Uh,
so the book of life is written in this four letter alphabet of a,
g,
C and t,
uh,
jeans down to act in isolation.
They tend to form networks,
sometimes a great complexity.
Uh,
they switch each other on and off and information swirls around these networks.
So we've been studying that,
the patterns of information,
the way it's stored and how the network architecture typology,
the wiring diagram,
if you like,
uh,
affects the behavior of that information.
And what is very clear from people who study biological networks is that if you
apply things like scaling laws,
that they're very different from random networks and otherwise evolution has
honed the topology and the architecture of these networks,
uh,
to have certain properties.
So when we think of life,
uh,
there,
there is a sort of reductionistic tendency to attribute biological functions to
specific genes or maybe collections of genes.
But we should really think in these network terms.
Uh,
and if we want to,
uh,
either reconfigure life or a cure,
some disease or something,
we really need to think of,
uh,
at,
at that network level,
the informational level now,
but it doesn't stop there.
Individual cells signal each other.
They transfer information.
Even bacteria can form biofilms.
They appear to be very clever when they're acting collectively.
But of course,
once you get up to,
uh,
the level of social insects,
then collective decision making,
VR information transfer becomes a really important subject.
We have a group per big group,
Asu,
uh,
working on,
how ants,
um,
get together that,
I mean,
that looks like they're having a conference,
but,
uh,
they are,
but they do have a little,
uh,
very complex repertoire of behavior.
But individually,
each hands is pretty stupid.
But collectively they're,
they're pretty smart.
So Baird's in flux.
That's another example anyone has read.
Today's papers were probably know that bees,
which also very clever,
I can not only play football,
but apparently they can do arithmetic.
So,
uh,
all of this has to do with information exchange and collected decision making.
Probably the most dramatic example of information deployed in the service of
life is the development of the embryo from single celled Zygote,
the exquisite choreography that is involved in getting all the right bits in the
right places at the right time.
And it's still not fully understood.
But Alan Turing,
as a matter of fact,
had a great interest in this and developed a,
a mathematical theory about how morphogenetic these will be.
Uh,
at that time her known chemicals might diffuse through our system and sort of
set up a three dimensional grid against which,
uh,
as we would now say,
Lang modern language that the genes would express themselves in the appropriate
way.
What this is really saying is that there is a dynamic chemical network and a
dynamic information network and these networks a couple together,
uh,
and there's complex feedback loops and the whole thing operates to give this
astonishing developmental pathway.
And then last but,
uh,
probably not least is what's between our ears.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
perhaps the best example of it,
the power of information in biology.
Once it leads to behavior and understanding at the level of human beings,
then it becomes a truly spectacular.
One.
Last point about this,
uh,
just last week,
can my colleagues published a study in which they look to David 28,000 genomes?
Uh,
and this is a,
um,
a planet wide network of,
uh,
organized information that they've mapped out here.
I won't go into the details except to say that the biosphere was the original
worldwide web and it's a web of information exchange.
Now this idea that life is really about information and a logic and a
information processing,
uh,
is certainly not my idea.
It didn't start with me.
Uh,
there was a very visionary paper in nature by Paneth,
the former president of the royal society could life,
logic and information.
And again,
I'll just read what he has to say.
We need to describe the molecular interactions and biochemical transformations
that take place in living organisms and then translate these descriptions into
the logic circuits that reveal how information is managed.
This analysis should not be confined to the flow of information from gene to
protein,
but should also be applied to all functions operating in cells and organisms.
And so what he's saying here is that we should perhaps think of life as a little
bit like electronics where you have these modules with each of which has a
function.
Uh,
these may just be logical functions.
There are many examples of logic gates in bacteria,
for example,
in gene regulatory circuits,
a that just operate and they can be wired together.
They just operate like a logic gates in computers.
And so this enables even simple organisms to carry out really very sophisticated
computations.
Now,
a lot of this was presaged by the co inventor of the Computer Nyman.
So cheering came up originally with the idea of a universal computer.
So that is a machine that could compute anything or could output anything that
was in principle,
computable given long enough.
And Paul Nyman,
uh,
drew a close analogy with what he called a universal constructor.
Universal constructor would be a machine that could take parts if he is provided
with enough parts and it could assemble them into anything that it was
programmed to do,
including itself,
it can make a copy of itself.
So he was interesting in the concept of a self reproducing machine.
Is it possible he said to build a machine,
they could construct any physical system including itself.
And in carrying that analysis through,
uh,
he preceded the logical architecture that we now know life on earth uses a,
that life is really an information replication of management system.
And in particular the dual row,
he foresaw the dual role of DNA.
Uh,
what'd I say?
Do row.
There are two things that can happen to DNA.
So it sits there,
this famous double helix and it's got instructions in the form of genes.
These can be read out.
So it can be a,
as it were,
a database for the life project.
It could be read out.
Uh,
and,
and in that sense it's in active mode.
It's,
it's sending that information out.
Uh,
but when the seller comes to divide,
that stops actually,
it doesn't stop the two things that go on together,
but nevermind,
ah,
there it goes,
flips to the other function.
It then is just not,
um,
uh,
information.
It's not a database.
It is then just a physical object,
a physical structure that gets replicated.
So two quite separate things happen to DNA.
One is it gets read out the other,
it gets replicated.
Nobody quite knows exactly how cells toggle between these two different
functions of DNA.
But in his notion of a self reproducing machine for nine months,
uh,
he,
he spoke to something called a supervisory unit,
which were basically say,
okay,
make this,
then stop my hand.
Nothing.
We're just copy the instruction set and take down instruction set and put it in
the project that so had to have what life does.
True self replication DNA has to have that dual hardware software function.
Now I'm software,
now I'm harbor.
So really important insight into the fundamental logic that runs life as we know
it and have an omen was absolutely right.
Uh,
this is the way that life does organize itself.
We're now,
uh,
let,
let me move on because I don't have too much longer.
Uh,
all of this raises the question of what is information.
I've been using that in a very sort of colloquial sense.
Um,
but I'd like to tell you a little bit about how we need to think of information,
not so much as something to talk about,
but as a physical variable that can enter into the laws of physics.
Because I provocatively said at the outset,
I agree with [inaudible],
we need a new type of physical law and I think it's a physical law that will
embed information in a fundamental way in the laws of physics.
These will be new laws of physics,
but it would be physics,
not magic.
Uh,
to do that you had to quantify information until most of the people here know
that this was Claude Shannon who developed information theory in the late 1940s
and define the binary digit or bit,
uh,
if you don't know their story,
one bit of information is what you get if you toss a coin and then see whether
it came down heads or tails.
Uh,
but,
um,
Shannon defined information in terms of reduction in uncertainty.
Uh,
you,
you've got a 50,
50 chance heads or tails where you look and see that uncertainty goes away.
And that's just one bit of uncertainty.
So that is all a standard stuff these days.
Uh,
but what I'm going to ask is can inflammation,
which seems to be a sort of abstract concept,
can they actually have physical cloud?
There's an analogy here with energy.
So as you're all aware,
uh,
information is something that can be instantiated in a wide variety of physical
systems.
If you want a copy,
a file from your computer to a flash drive,
you can do that.
You keep the information,
you can then send it down.
An optical fiber is photons.
Uh,
there's any number of different ways you could store all that information.
The information is conserved.
It's independent of the substrate,
just like energy.
Uh,
you can convert electrical energy into mechanical energy or gravitational energy
or chemical energy.
The energy stays the same,
but it's manifestation or instantiation,
uh,
can be passed from one thing to another.
So just as energy has a sort of independent existence,
but it's always tied to matter.
So information we talk about it as if it's a thing with an independent
existence,
but it is always tied to matter.
So to fully understand how information operates in living systems,
we have to understand how information couples to matter,
not just as a way of speaking,
but,
uh,
in a law like manner.
And it turns out that,
uh,
the answer,
the beginnings of announcer,
we're already there,
uh,
in the 19th century with the work of James Clark,
Maxwell and Maxwell's demon.
Now let me just explain this concept.
So Maxwell who unified electricity and magnetism also made seminal contributions
to the theory of heat.
And in a letter to a friend,
I mean this was a while to Fuzz,
is called a thought experiment.
He envisaged a tiny being soon to be called a demon who could perceive
individual molecules in their pallets and then salt them into fast and slow
categories.
So what you see there is a shutter mechanism and the Wiley Demon will open the
shutter to let fast moving particles go from right to left and slow moving
particles go the other direction.
And Maxwell argued that that could be done without any expenditure of energy.
It was a,
in principle,
you could just,
it was just a matter of letting the molecules,
uh,
move through.
And if you do that,
because molecular speed is a measure of temperature,
you end up with the left side hot on the right side.
And then an engineer could build you a heat engine that could do useful work to
run off their temperature gradient.
So this was a device Maxwell's demon of converting information about the
molecules into work,
heat into work.
Without any further ado.
And that's in flagrant violation of the second law of thermodynamics.
The most fundamental law of the universe.
And that's the law that we think of when we say he goes from hot to cold.
Uh,
for example,
if you put a snow person,
I guess we should call it next to a fire,
uh,
the snow person melts and the f five,
you know,
loses heat.
It doesn't go the other way.
You don't find that there's more and more snow on the right.
Uh,
and the flames get hotter and hotter.
So that's very familiar.
Nobody really would contest that except some who might be thinking,
well,
how would I want to back up my refrigerator?
Doesn't that take a heat from the cold interior and put it into the warm
kitchen?
And the answer is yes.
And you pay an electricity bill for that.
In other words,
given energy,
yes,
you can make heat flow up hill or backwards or reverse the Arrow of time,
however you want to think of it.
Uh,
but Maxwell's demon does it.
It's not plugged into the national grid.
Maxwell's demon does it for nothing but not quite for nothing because Maxwell's
demon is using information to gain a firmer than I make advantage.
And that says the information is a type of fuel.
And sure enough,
it is a type of fjord.
And the last three or four years,
there'd been a flood of papers and experiments,
uh,
making what I called information engines.
These engines run on information,
power alone.
My favorite one is in Finland.
This is an inflammation powered refrigerator.
Yeah,
you can actually do this.
Um,
each got an efficiency of 75% of converting bits,
uh,
into,
into work or into a energy.
And it's not really going to spark a kitchen revolution in the near future
because this is nano technology is,
is on a nano scale.
But nevertheless,
it establishes the important principle.
The Maxwell was right.
So this is a Maxwell demon.
There's one just a couple of months ago reported in Korea that has more than 98%
conversion efficiency of information into work.
Uh,
but it was,
um,
a couple of,
uh,
of giants of the field,
of the theory of computation working at IBM,
Rolf Landauer.
And then Charles Bennett who really put all this together about 20 years ago,
they were interested in the fundamental limits of computation.
Uh,
what I often say to people is,
um,
uh,
this machine here is the laptop.
But you know,
I very rarely put it on my lap.
And I think these days people tend to not do that.
But if you do put it on your lap,
you and it just gets hot and that heat is a wasted,
in fact,
I read somewhere that the entire heat output from the world's computing industry
is more than the power requirements of Denmark.
And increasingly a lot of that's going to big coin in a bitcoin is costing
staggering amounts of energy.
Now,
you know,
why do you expend energy like that?
And so what Landau was interested in is how do the laws of computing and the
laws of thermodynamics interconnect?
And they do because every time a bit is flipped or erased it model the point
that you generate a little bit of heat and that could be reduced enormously.
And I just ask you to think that your brain is like a mega what super
supercomputer,
but it runs on the equivalent of a light bulb,
small light bulb.
So it's,
it's possible to greatly reduce the amount of heat which is expended.
Uh,
Landauer and later Charles Bennett were interested,
could it be reduced to zero?
Could you have reversible computation?
Uh,
and all that's in the book I won't get into with here that have enough time,
but what they identify,
at least what Charles Bennett identified,
uh,
is that you're not getting something for nothing here,
mate.
Maxwell's steam and looks like it's some sort of perpetual motion machine.
It's,
it's really not because,
uh,
you get a little bit,
you can always grab a little bit of a thermodynamic advantage,
but if you wanted something for your kitchen,
you'd have to go on doing it again and again.
And again.
You'd have to have a cycle.
And in order to operate a Maxwell demon and the cycle,
the poor thing gets his brain clogged up with information because remember it's
got to observe store act and then that's in its register and that register will
fill up and fill up.
And so at some stage it has to be cleared out,
brainwashed,
reset and started again.
And that act of resetting the register generates as much entropy as you have
gained.
So overall in the universe,
the second law is still a bade,
but nevertheless,
at the level of nanotechnology,
uh,
you can gain an advantage,
on here as a matter of interest.
For the more mathematically inclined is the second law of thermodynamics that
explicitly includes information.
So if you put an information termi measured in bits,
put an information to him in to that equation,
the books balance.
Now you might be thinking,
well,
this is all well and good for nanotechnologists.
What's he got to do with life?
And the answer is what life is all about.
Nano technology that we're full of molecular machines,
many of them are Maxwell demons.
Chuntering away doing the business of life.
There are many examples.
It reads about them in the book,
but I'm just going to give you one to give you the flavor of this cause I need
to wind this up in a moment.
Um,
the,
uh,
what's going on in your head says,
I hope you're paying attention,
uh,
is that your neurons are signaling each other.
There's these signals a little bit like electrical wires,
the axons in your brain,
but it's the,
it's not like a flow of electrons through the brain.
What happens is that there's like a wave of polarization,
electric polarization across the membrane of the Axon.
And there are these holes in the membrane that are gated,
just like Maxwell's demon.
They can be opened and closed and the brain does open and close them.
It gets inflammation from the neighboring pattern.
Electrical pattern makes decisions to open and close them and lets through
sodium ions in one direction and potassium ions in the other direction with
great fidelity and no energy expenditure,
which is why all this can happen with just a light bulb.
And so that's one great example of life using a Maxwell demon type advice.
Uh,
in this case in our heads.
I want to wrap this up by talking about how did all this stuff happened in the
first place.
What Darwin,
uh,
famously gave us a wonderful account of how life had evolved over billions of
years on earth,
but he refused to be drawn on the origin of life.
The problem of life's origin,
uh,
mean rubbish.
He said,
thinking of this one might as well think of the origin of matter.
And when I was a student,
the feeling was very much summed up by crick.
Life seems almost a miracle.
He said so many of the conditions for it to get Gehring.
This didn't stop.
Some people like a Stanley Miller attentive to cook up life in the lab by,
uh,
in this case,
putting some common gaseous and sparking electricity through them.
Uh,
this,
uh,
whole prebiotic synthesis,
enterprise continues to this day.
They've got a bit further,
but not very much.
But I think there's an absolutely fundamental reason why we're not going to
solve the secret of life,
uh,
by mixing stuff up in a chemistry lab.
And the answer,
I've said it all along is that life's distinguishing feature is the way it
organizes and manages information and no greater example can I give then the
genetic code itself,
uh,
the,
the information on your DNA is coded information has got to be decoded before it
means anything before it has biological functionality.
And of course,
what we'd like to know is how did this come to exist in the first place from
some sort of molecular Maloo random forces?
How did a genetic code arise?
How come molecules write code?
It's very deeply baffling.
I think we're a long way from understanding that.
Uh,
but to truly finish,
I want to tell you that it goes much beyond that.
And so I'm going to finish on a sort of lighthearted though,
but it's actually a very profound,
uh,
which is that information about energy goes beyond the gene.
There's a whole field called epigenetics,
which recognizes that,
but the particular epigeneticist sign like best,
uh,
Mike Levin at Tufts University,
he's got a,
the Allen Discovery Center there where he likes to work with these worms called
planaria are teachers love these because they have a head and a tail,
even have a little brain.
Apparently you see the eyes at one end tail at the other.
The great thing is if you chop them in half,
then the town makes a head and the head makes a tail.
Uh,
and so children love that.
You see the,
uh,
the,
there we go.
Uh,
you can get two of them and you can go on doing this.
You get more and more and more of them.
And I asked Mike,
do they have ever have sex?
And he said,
well,
they do,
but they prefer to be chopped up.
Now what,
what might can do is,
what is he's discovered is that when you chop them in,
chop chop through them,
the electric polarization across the membrane.
That's what I was talking about with the axons.
All cells had that they will have a potential difference across the member and
their pump protons out to keep that,
that gets altered around the wound.
Uh,
so the path,
there's an electrical pattern there.
Now he can muck around with that pattern with drugs that sort of alter the ionic
concentration and so on.
And uh,
when he fiddles like that,
he can end up making a two headed and two tailed.
Well,
and again,
I asked him are the two Taub one's really stupid and he said it doesn't seem to
make a lot of difference where they head to head on up,
but,
and this is a mind blowing thing.
If he chops up at two headed worm and the two halves,
you might think that would restore the original phenotype.
But now it makes two two headed worms.
And the same thing with the two two tail worms.
The point is they've got identical DNA.
So a visitor from Mars might think these are different species,
but they've got identical DNA.
So this is Epi genetic inheritance,
it's often called.
So this is a way that the information about the phenotype,
about the physical form is propagated from one to the next,
not in the genes.
And we don't know how it's propagated.
We're working with him to try to figure out where is that information being
stored and processed and passed on.
Uh,
it raises,
uh,
this,
entire question about electrically encoded software by bioelectric memory.
And where does it come from?
Um,
a postscript to this is that he took a lot of,
um,
and his colleagues,
he's,
he has a large research group.
Uh,
it took a lot of these worms chopped the middle,
the middle's out and sent all these middles off to the space station.
Uh,
there it is.
And,
um,
when the middle's came back,
about 15% of them had two heads,
you see?
So they,
he,
but they basically lost the head down on earth,
but it came back with two.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this was much publicized in the press a couple of years ago here in,
in Britain that was described as a two heady flatworm stand.
The scientists boffins baffled disease.
Uh,
Mike Levin has no idea what a boffin is.
I had to explain all this.
Um,
but whenever it puffins get mentioned,
there was baffled.
Uh,
so,
uh,
this takes us beyond the gene to epigenetic control,
mechanical,
electrical and gravitational effects can all,
uh,
determine what genes are switched on and off and therefore informational
patterns.
Uh,
and that leads us to questions like,
is there an electrical code to go alongside it?
Uh,
can we use this a electrical leverage to cure things like cancer or birth
defects,
defects or repair tissues.
We came into this,
so I came into this lecture,
uh,
w with the quantum mechanics and I would like to leave it with quantum
mechanics,
uh,
because I think that the true answer to finding her information capitals to
matter in biological systems,
what probably come at the same interface where we are into large molecules that
have quantum effects.
But we,
some people suspect that these quantum effects will become modified when they're
sufficiently large.
And there's an entire field of quantum biology struggling to get out where
people are conjecturing that if life is so clever at manipulating bits,
cannot manipulate cubits as well.
And of course,
quantum computing,
Google is invested in that.
Uh,
this is a a billion dollar research,
multibillion dollar research project around the world to build a quantum
computer.
Uh,
and somehow I feel that if quantum computing is achievable but surprise me a
great deal,
if that was the first human technology that had never been found in nature,
everything else we've invented nature got their first,
uh,
is quantum computing to be the exception.
I somehow don't think so.
And I somehow think that quantum biology and the convergence of nanotechnology,
chemistry,
physics,
information theory in that realm,
which still likes a name that's going to be the next great frontier of physics.
That's my last word on the subject.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
to keep my information as fuel.
Does that imply that and Maxwell's demon,
the information is being destroyed?
Uh,
well,
uh,
I
did explain that set,
but perhaps rather quickly that when the register is clear to repeat the cycle,
that's where the information is destroyed and the,
and the entropy of the system rises.
Uh,
so it's limited to the,
basically the storage capacity of the demons register.
Uh,
and so this,
uh,
entire field is still not absolutely completely worked out to everybody's
satisfaction.
Um,
that people say,
well,
suppose when you had an infinite supply of demons or supposing you store that
information,
not a in any,
uh,
energy land landscape,
but some other physical variable.
And I might there be some way of getting around this.
It's all active actively under investigation.
But the key point is that the information is used to gain a thermodynamic
advantage to convert heat into work,
but in a small amount.
And that if you go on doing that cumulatively sooner or later you have to erase
the information in the register and then you get back the entropy,
the entropy disadvantage,
it compensates you for the game that you've had.
So it's not a free lunch,
but,
but if the name of the game is to play the margins of thermal dynamics on a nano
scale,
then that's certainly what life is doing.
But I didn't have time.
Life is doing much more than just playing a thermodynamic game.
Uh,
it's also doing this complex organization and coded information management and
so on.
And all of that has to come in any true understanding of the nature of life.
And so,
uh,
the,
the game of chess I skipped over but would have been if I'd have had time and
attempt to explain how I think we can capture that concept of functional or
meaningful information in a context,
uh,
in a new type of physical law,
which was what trading of the suggesting it would be a sort of top down law in
which the,
um,
just to give you the words in which the,
uh,
dynamic,
I'll update rules if you like.
The evolution of the system will be a function of the state of a system.
Quite unlike any law of physics we've had so far where the laws are fixed,
the states change with time.
We're advocating that the,
um,
the laws are a function of the state and that gives a whole new pathways to
complexity and we've done some computer models to foster that,
that claim.
So that's why I think the new type of physical law comes in.
But this is still a work in progress.
Do Think,
uh,
physics can explain consciousness?
Ah,
wow.
There's the how chapter book,
the other book on consciousness.
I thank you for mentioning that.
I found most of my life being a cosmologists and so I've been interested in the
origin of the universe and then as is obvious,
more recently I've become interested in the origin of life.
And I like to say there are really three great origin problems,
university life and then consciousness.
I think we've cracked the problem more or less.
So the origin of the universe,
that's the easy one.
Uh,
the origin of life is very tough,
but I think we're on the case.
The origin of consciousness.
We don't even know how to frame that.
However,
that hasn't stopped me writing a chapter about it.
Uh,
this is,
this is a chapter in which I more or less,
uh,
outline what all the problems are rather than they come up with the solutions.
But there is one thing that I warmed to and it's part of this power of
information.
There's a whole,
I should say,
not just biological networks network and researchers who like these things.
One of these is a Giulio Tononi.
Uh,
he's a neuroscientist and he's defined something called integrated information.
and so it's often said that the whole is greater than the sum of its parts and
never more so then for consciousness.
Uh,
and this is a way of attempting to mathematize that feeling that the collective
system has greater power than the components.
Uh,
and he can demonstrate that for certain types of networks,
we,
certain types of feedback loops.
So in principle,
if you believed his definition,
which very few people do,
but it's,
you know,
heroic try,
uh,
you'd be able to say,
well,
there's a thermostat conscious.
That's a famous conundrum,
uh,
you know,
is a radio consciousness and conscious and he could give an answer.
Did.
He actually has a way of defining a consciousness meter,
not just the life meet their consciousness meter.
And it all depends on the architecture,
the information architecture in the network.
So that,
that's something that I,
I do describe and,
and I should probably say at this stage,
having mentioned that there's a network of collaborators.
Um,
uh,
almost everything that I write in my book,
originates with my young collaborators,
Sarah Walker,
and are magnificent group of students and postdocs.
And Sarah is so gracious,
she said,
but everything I tell you I got from here in the first place.
And so,
um,
uh,
but I,
but,
but she's,
she's very smart.
And so a lot of these ideas are actually has,
um,
in Alaska
a few years I've been hearing about the free energy principle,
which tries to define a life as being something that can mirror its environment
and lake coming up,
coming up with a definition of life,
uh,
as a system that's capable of mirroring it environment.
And I was wondering if you'd heard of this and what you are taught are,
so is this the work of Jeremy England?
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And he and his staff does get a bit of a mantra here.
Not as big a mention as in Dan Brown's book,
but he is the,
I guess,
get some engine.
Um,
and uh,
it's connected.
I mean it's this whole point about,
uh,
par.
Um,
these pathways are often very complex in biology of going from here to here on
how much,
uh,
that,
so I should suggest get technical technical for a moment.
The word free energy has a very specific meaning to a physicist.
It doesn't mean as energy for free.
I mean it's available.
Energy is probably a better way of looking at it.
And the F that appeared in that equation I showed that had the item or that is
the,
the free energy and information has to come into that.
Uh,
and so it's,
it,
it is very much connected with the same thing.
There's something called [inaudible] is inequality that goes into this.
And,
and in in the book you will see a yard in scares contraction that can turn
information into work and it looks like a child's mobile.
It's a,
it's a thought experiment.
But,
but as I say,
these things,
not,
not that particular button,
but these sorts of things are being built now.
This is part of the technology.
Uh,
so I just have a clarification question regarding the a Maxwell demon.
So I think,
I don't understand why the demons information content as it does its job is
going up.
Like,
you know,
I would have imagined that the demon just decide to own a certain speed
threshold yes.
In the direction then let's every molecule approaching it at a faster speed than
that.
True.
So it just has one bit of information that is maintaining
a deck,
but the team has to be able to observe and assess the speeds of those molecules.
And then is this one coming fast enough?
And then yes,
open the shutter.
You see,
so it's a,
and the person who analyze this in great detail.
In the 1920s,
Leo Silat,
uh,
he simplified everything and had a single molecule in a box with a movable
screen.
Uh,
it's called Zillow.
Jen,
Jen.
It's much discussed in my book.
And,
uh,
the,
the demon would then ask the question is the molecule on the right or on the
left?
And then he said the screen and extract the work.
Uh,
but then in order to repeat that cycle,
you would have to eliminate the inflammation from its register or accumulate it
and then accumulates.
If the,
if it's a fine,
I register then eventually all this we're grinds to a halt.
But I mean,
you're to say,
well,
you know,
what about this,
what about that?
Because this is still a subject which is picked over.
So Charles Bennett,
who in my view,
a settled issue to my satisfaction,
has his detractors and say,
but what about if you did this?
And surprising that.
Uh,
but I think overall,
the,
the key message is that it's not the Silat thought it was the act of acquisition
of the information that in order for the demons and know what the molecules were
doing,
we'd have to expend energy and that energy would raise the entropy.
And that's where the books balance wasn't at that stage.
It's at the clearing of the register stage.
So it really is,
uh,
this is where thermodynamics and computing really do mesh together because it's
not the physics of sensing.
It's the physics of computation that saves the second law.
So there's very,
very deep connection between the world of computing and life,
uh,
which I think is sort of increasing the Elvis there.
Everybody here we see it.
You'd have boiled down to its essential with see large engine and Bennett's
resolution of the demon paradox.
Um,
maybe I will have another crack at another direction from on the topic of
consciousness.
If we can kind of unify everything,
get all the physics,
smoke the information,
what does it say about free will of the individual?
Right.
Uh,
you've,
you've raised a vast subject across and I could stand here for a very long time
talking about free.
Well,
I can't do that.
I have no choice.
I have to go off and do another event.
Uh,
but just very briefly and of course I do allude to it in the book.
Um,
let me just cut to the chase and tell you my own position on free bowl.
Freewill I think is a feeling that we have more to the point,
and this comes out in the book,
um,
that freewill is closely connected to our sense that time is flowing.
Now a physicists were telling you time count flow.
That's an illusion.
But it's a necessary illusion for us.
They'll live our lives,
we live our lives as if time flows.
It doesn't,
it doesn't flow.
Uh,
there are simply intervals between events and states of your brain.
So I think that the illusion of the flow of time is because we convince
ourselves that we have,
I've used the word we ourselves conserved selves,
that I'm the same self was I had when I was a child.
In other words,
that the self stays unchanged.
The world changes around us.
That gives us an impression of the flow of time.
Think that's back to front.
I think the world doesn't change.
There's simply successive states,
time isn't flowing.
But at each successive moment you're all slightly different self from what you
were before.
So a lot of mutual information between the yeah,
yes,
the self.
But it is different.
You're a different person today.
From what you were yesterday.
So I think our sense of freedom has to do with getting that back to front.
Uh,
anyway,
read the book
on the last slide on quantum computation and quantum biology and the link,
are there any
proposals for a physical system that inside biology could do useful quantum
computation in the sense that how will accubid B Oh,
coherence of a cubit to a bunch of cubits be maintaining temperature,
moisture,
et cetera.
Okay.
So first of all,
there's the biggest subject of quantum biology.
Generally,
can biology deploy any quantum effects involving things I can tanglement and
toweling and so on.
The answer to that is almost certainly yes.
And I give four examples in that particular chapter in the book while having to
do with the in photosynthesis the transfer of energy from the light harvesting
center to the reaction Chemical Reaction Center.
Now that has to do with bird navigation,
extraordinary thing,
um,
or factory responsive flies.
Uh,
and you know,
some other,
other things in there.
The one that really strikes me because my colleagues at Asu doing experiments is
the way that electron tunneling through organic molecules can be dramatically
different according to the sequence,
say if it's a protein,
the nucleotide sequence,
a colleague of mine said a change one amino acid in a cycle on and off switch.
So it looks like biology has fine tuned by natural selection,
fine tune these organically functional molecules to have special quantum
tunneling properties.
So I think there's very little doubt that quantum mechanics is playing a role in
biology.
Uh,
what's not clear is whether this is just a few quirky little things that life
has stumbled across and taken advantage of,
or whether it's the tip of a quantum iceberg.
But your question specifically was,
uh,
can they be cubit processing?
There was a claim,
uh,
by a Purveyor Patel from India that,
that indeed was taking place,
that it was actually Grover's algorithm being implemented in the genetic code.
He's backed away from that claim in recent years.
Uh,
so it was a sort of Nice try,
gained a lot of attention.
I agree with you.
And that warm,
wet environment,
it's very hard to see how decoherence wouldn't kill this stone dead,
but that would also be true of some of the other quantum effects.
And,
uh,
again,
there's a,
a lot of work being done to see how,
uh,
the quantum processes could be screened,
could screen out the environmental noise and so on.
Uh,
and so it could be the biology has got a trick or two to teach people working in
quantum computing.
There are certainly some people who do work in quantum computing who are aware
of this,
but this is all very much the cutting edge,
I think we'll find out in the coming years.
Thank you very much for coming,
Paul.
That was thoroughly,
thoroughly enjoyable.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Paul Davies.
[inaudible].